c'est une histoire de mariage avec
plusieurs mariages et un seul et même
épouse heures elle et voici lui le voilà
c'est le soleil le même pour toutes ces
histoires sont celles de ses multiples
épouses halle avec toutes ces pots qui
se donne à lui pendant les mois d'été
il en est de ces mariages peau au soleil
ce qu'il en est des autres il en est de
bon de délicieux il en est aussi de
malheureux de rapts et et de dramatique
première histoire premier mariage
elle est brune c'est le coup de fouet
elle adore ils l'adorent verbe de rien
pas de problème entre et les fassent
tous ces soucis divers
il supprime même la cne
mais attention évitez de garder le sel
sur le visage même pas ça soit utilisé
une crème hydratante et entretenir les
bons rapports avec du thé très forts
passés en tamponnant bilan mariage
réussi donc pas d'histoire presque pas
deuxième histoire deuxième mariage elle
est blonde régime de sportif lui
toujours le même lyon impétueux sujet
des coups de colère elle rougit lui juge
va mal c'est l'incompatibilité elle
pleure tous les cataplasmes de fécule de
pomme de terre ne peuvent plus rien pour
elle
soyons pratique déclare en état
d'urgence séparation de corps total
pendant huit jours ensuite
ensuite ils ne doivent pas rester
ensemble plus de 20 minutes par jour le
salut est dans l'ombre et dans l'eau
l'eau de mer est un parfait sérum
physiologique qui traite les brûlures et
fortifie la peau ajoutez des vitamines
et des crèmes généreuse et protectrice
matin midi et soir
tout cela pour éviter à la rentrée les
cicatrices de cette union orageuse
troisième histoire troisième mariage et
les rousses de paris n'en était parfois
elle est maligne l'a séduit ce qu'elle a
fait un régime à base de vitamine pp
des litres d'huile sur sa peau
et de l'eau de loterie cinq minutes le
soir des fleurs des fruits des fleurs
des fruits des fleurs des fruits des
fleurs des fruits lui tout feu tout
flamme bilan c'est un bon ménage
pourtant qui l'eût cru prévoyante elle
pense encore à l'hiver en faisant un
tout petit masque peeling pour effacer
les tâches qui arrive souvent aux
rousses
quatrième histoire c'est la dernière ils
étaient faits pour s'entendre
ils s'entendaient même très bien depuis
pas mal de temps
puis tout d'un coup friction irritation
on ne pouvait plus le supporter lui
désolé vraiment désolé c'était de
l'allergie que dit la pratique elle dit
c'est une crise ça si on s'est trop vu
trop peiné la peau a besoin de repos on
dirais même qu'elle a une indigestion de
rayons solaires
il faut se mettre à l'ombre boit
énormément d'eau minérale et du jus de
fruits tomates abricots qui disait
d'élèves tilleuls et camomille bilan
rien n'est perdu tout peut s'arranger et
s'arranger avec des marques de crème
très nourrissante posée sous serviettes
chaudes et sèches
conclusion les meilleurs mariage sont
ceux où sous tour à tour avec douceur et
avec patience est un conseil de madame
de maintenon
donc soyons prudent patient en dur en
prévoyant exigeante et avertie et bonnes
vacances
[Musique]